Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David p. Speaking of chris
christie and joe Biden, here's a caller
asking about exactly those two people.
Speaker 3: David, do you
think that Chris Christie.
Speaker 4: Would beat.
Speaker 3: Joe Biden?
And my next question would be, do you think
Chris Christie if he did win the nominee?
Would you start going after.
Speaker 4: Anti-woke crap too?
Speaker 1: Okay, so two questions there. If
it were Christie versus Biden, does Christie
have a shot? Second question, If Christie became
the nominee, would he go anti-woke? Let's answer
the second one first, because it's simpler.
The Anti-woke stuff is more useful within the
Republican primary than in the general election.
Why? Because most of the country actually agrees
with the woke side of most issues. So if Chris
Christie doesn't go anti-woke while running in
the primary, he is not going to go anti-woke as
a general election candidate that I am confident
in the first question. If the matchup were
Christie versus Biden in November of 2024,
could Christie win? I believe the answer is yes.
I believe that if MAGA was soundly defeated,
if Trump really crumbles and what I mean by
that is he's indicted a third time, it becomes
absolutely impossible to even be out on the
campaign trail because he's just busy with three
different criminal defenses. Republicans abandoned
him. Imagine they select Chris Christie. I believe
that this would actually create a resurgence among
the Republican electorate where all of these folks
who have been dissuaded from even participating
because they're disgusted with Trump are They
just think Trump is the wrong direction for
the party? I believe all of those folks would
get engaged. I believe also that there are some
people who voted for Biden in 2020 because they
were so disgusted with Trump, who, if there was
a reasonable Republican, would actually go back
to voting Republican. And so I'm not here to tell
you Christie would definitely beat Joe Biden. But
if Trump is running even with Biden, I do believe
that Chris Christie has a solid shot of defeating
Biden in a general election. I'm not hoping for
that. I'm answering the caller's question. We have
a fantastic bonus show for you today. We're going
to talk about the coming heat wave in Texas. Are
they actually prepared for it this time? We will
talk about Cornell West now after announcing that
he's running as a People's Party candidate. Also
seeking the Green Party nomination, I'm going to
be honest with you, it's all a complete and total
mess. And we will give you the latest. Not so
good news about Tesla's self-driving system,
which I have tested out myself, by the way. All
of those stories and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up and join Pacman.